you managed to quit your job become
financially independent you've got a
little nice portfolio and you're
building a great brand in the property
Community how long did it take you from
a really commitment to getting to the
point where you could actually leave
work I actually left my job before I saw
the new deal because in my ID job I made
about two grand so how the heck am I
making three grand in one transaction
you don't get paid for your time you get
paid for your value obviously doing it
now it seems normal but most people
don't do this to make money it doesn't
have to take long I just had my first 10
grand profit once last month the best
things in life are free but may as well
cost a year if you don't have the time
to enjoy them I've got nothing to lose
I'm going to teach you this I'm going to
bet on myself I'm going to make a plan
work
[Music]
thank you Ellie Henry from Henry homes
how you doing today bro I'm good I'm
good Sam thanks for coming down I really
appreciate your time so you are now a
full-time property investor entrepreneur
I am indeed yeah congratulations thank
you so much thank you tell me about what
made you want to get into property in
the first place and then I want to go
through your story how you managed to
quit your job become financially
independent you've got a little nice
portfolio and you're building a great
brand in the property community so we're
going to be learning a lot of nuggets
but firstly what was it about property
that got you interested in doing it in
the first place first of all I want to
say thank you to my Lord Jesus Christ
it's why I'm here today he's the main
reason why mainly I always thought kind
of I would be in business so from a
young age of about
14 to 16. my best subject in school was
business as well as French other
languages I speak and my goal and
aspiration was either playing football
or get into business I bought my first
property in 2017 about five years ago
and my parents pushed me to do that so I
kind of knew I wanted to do some kind of
business but it was only last year after
a few tries of Adventures like clothing
podcasting where I came across property
and that's kind of the thing that stuck
the most so you're kind of like a
natural entrepreneur how old are you 27
27. do you think a lot of people have
got like a natural entrepreneurial Flair
in them but they're just sort of caged
in their job and it never comes out yeah
um even like going to school I was the
one selling selling foods and whatnot to
make money so I think probably as you
grow it kind of gets dumbed down it does
and even when you're a kid if you're a
kid and you say to your teacher I want
to be an astronaut a more bad they'll
tell you to be realistic get good exams
you know then go to college or uni get a
job settle down so how did you end up
working in a job as what we did Finance
I.T yeah Finance I.T so actually I went
to UNI before that and I dropped out
after about two about two years I was
studying economics but for what I wanted
to do in finance I kind of realized well
even if I'm not doing business if I want
to do this this degree doesn't really
make sense parents didn't agree with me
but I did it of course they didn't
because every parent wants their kid to
go to you now yeah 100 so you went to
use some economics with the view of
getting into Finance yeah and what kind
of Finance did you want to be doing or
did you were you one of those guys that
just went to UNI just because I was
thinking maybe like to be an analyst of
some sort but funny enough when I got
into the finance world at entry level
position I kind of realized that to work
my way up I don't even need a degree
yeah and to even do this so I went from
Finance to it because those were kind of
my two kind of favorite subjects right
in school as well so at what point then
like I'm seeing a conflict because
you're talking about I.T and finance and
like job corporate career and then
you're talking about selling sweets at
school yeah and hustling and being an
entrepreneur so what happened so it
during that time I kind of realized that
I was gonna be patient enough it was
around the age of 22. be patient enough
in whatever job I was working to try
other you know entrepreneurial Ventures
while I was working until I found the
right one I don't know why but I kind of
had the inkling from when I got that
Finance job when I was about 21 that I
wouldn't work my way up because I saw
people working their way up and they
just became so time poor and they became
like slaves to their jobs yeah yeah so I
kind of just stayed at a steady position
that's true bro you know what you know
the amount of people that because the
thing is they go to UNI they get a job
and then the next thing is that you want
a pay rise you want the promotion but
every time you get a promotion actually
you've now got more responsibility more
work more weight on your shoulders so
you might have a bigger house but you
ain't got time to spend in that house
because you're going to be at work you
might have as nicer car what's that
called I'm going to drive you back from
work so you tried a few things
definitely fashion this that yeah yeah
why did you decide what was it that made
you go yes to property when you came
across the the property angle property
because I knew for a while property was
a safe asset bricks and mortar you can
see it where did you buy your house that
your parents told you South London
Croydon and Croydon how did you afford
to buy a house in Croydon so we we kind
of saved up me and my partner so we
saved up for I think about two years to
build that deposit for that apartment
right one-bit apartment and you were
just like living or renting it living in
it do you live in it now no not anymore
no no game chat all changes up
everything's switched exactly yeah so
you come along to my crash course I
think it was correct and then what
happened so I came along so even prior
to that I was watching your videos it's
funny a few years ago I came across one
of your videos Finance Freedom Challenge
and it kind of stuck out to me but I
never pursued further but I came across
it last year summer around June July and
I thought
I can see the results I can see what you
do in other people's lives and
this is my opportunity to jump I will
continue trying until I find what works
for me so then I came to the one pound
crash course in July 2022. no actually
last year now yeah so your strategy has
been you've been doing rental rents
service accommodation you've been doing
deal sourcing you've been doing kind of
a bit of everything how long did it take
you from a really committing to getting
to the point where you could actually
leave work and become you know
financially independent well that's a
really interesting one because
in a kind of anomaly kind of situation I
actually left my job before I saw the
New Deal and going back to the point of
my apartment so I moved out of my
apartment into a bigger place to use the
apartment I was living in get refurbed
touched up as a service accommodation
okay of course yeah when you saw how
much money you make a service
accommodation you think you're gonna
think well I've got to be resourceful I
already got a house yeah and you turned
that house into a service accommodation
yeah yeah it was really like fearful
kind of situation because you know I'm
sure a lot of people who are working
right now just going from paycheck to
paycheck you know would be quite afraid
to leave a job for any kind of reason I
didn't have any safety in there I didn't
have any savings how did you afford to
join the academy
I didn't have the money so you use
someone else's money
um I basically got a loan and I've
gotten people to let people know yeah I
got a loan it wasn't my own money but
because of the results that I saw and I
really wanted to bet on myself I thought
you know what I've got nothing to lose
you know I'm going to take the risk I'm
going to bet on myself I'm gonna make
the plan work because I think people
will invest money into like crypto and
and even property which is a very safe
investment but then they won't invest in
themselves they'll be like oh I'll
invest in this and this and this and
hope it works out they'll bet on
property they'll bet on crypto they'll
bet on lots of things but they won't
invest in or bet on themselves yeah it
doesn't make any sense property is the
second best investment the best is
yourself especially when you think about
going uni where you're investing like
tens of thousands yeah so it's the same
concept so why I don't know why people
kind of see it much differently so you
invested in yourself you evolved into
the academy and in the first very first
thing that you did was you turned your
was it a flat yes you're flat into a
service accommodation so what was how
did you do that so with your training
um I basically renovated
got a new paint job fixed the oven
random numbers it was still quite risky
because I was still very fresh and I
didn't really understand service
accommodation yeah but I kind of guessed
it's in a good area it has to work
really and you got the support and you
can bounce ideas around and then did you
manage it yourself or did you get a
channel manager or so managing it myself
me and my partner were managing that
I'll never forget the day when the first
book came in after I think 12 hours I
was driving and uh a bit emotional but I
shed a tear or two because I genuinely
realized that I've been lied to right
for most of my adulthood up until that
point where you had to go from paycheck
to paycheck you can only be paid at the
end of the month but we've seen that
money come in which I think was about
1.5 grand for 10 night booking it opened
my mind and one of your famous sayings I
really enjoy and like is when you see it
you can't unsee it yeah and that I think
was the with the stuff yeah yeah so you
saw the first book incoming you got a
10-day booking one and a half Grand and
you're like damn damn did you worry
though did you did you think am I going
to keep getting bookings I did worry a
bit but then also you know I was doing
the deal sourcing at the same time right
um and I thought okay I need to got no
job got no safety net I'm it's on me and
I have to make the plan work so that's
if I remember rightly you actually stood
up at an event and you were like I just
quit my job and everyone clapped I was
like amazing how many deals have you got
and you were like none and I was like oh
crap
but you just knew that it was going to
work yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's hard I
guess you just have to believe in
yourself yeah no one can believe in you
more than you can right might be a bit
crazy but yeah yeah yeah so you're deal
sourcing then tell me about your first
deal you sold first deal sold after
about six seven weeks very
nerve-wracking and I remember the first
day I did sell that deal
when I saw the money in the bank again
that was kind of like a I've just got
three grandis
this doesn't make sense how how is this
possible because in my ID job being
transparent I made about two grand in a
month in a month yeah so how the heck am
I making free grand in one transaction
it just it seems stupid to be true right
it was crazy and also as well the thing
is that a lot of people don't get is
that you don't get paid for your time
you get paid for your value 100 and with
the academy you'd learned a valuable
skill of finding deals negotiating them
people haven't got and another thing is
when you're in property it's the numbers
are so big if someone's buying a house
in London for 300 400 000 and you've
packaged it and you've knocked it down
by 10 well 10 it's like 30 grand
if they happen to pay you three grand to
save 30 grand the numbers are so big
your Piggly three grand seems like
nothing because when you're buying a
house you've got to pay stamp Duty
solicitors mortgage brokers you've got
all these fees you're just an extra fee
yeah one extra small thing but from your
perspective if you're doing that like
how many deals on average are you
selling now like a month would you say
about two so if you're sending a couple
deals a month which is on top of your
rent to rent something you're doing
that's like six seven Grand 100 which is
a pretty good income they're very good
obviously doing it now it seems normal
but most people don't do this what kind
of deals are you selling L.A mainly BR
deals right so deals properties that
need work and where you can push the
value up and it's Henry Holmes is that
just your deal selling or is that
everything you do in property so Henry
Holmes is the service accommodation okay
and it is the deal sourcing okay so
Henry Holmes is just you that's your
property company and you're doing
management you're doing sources One Stop
Shop kind of thing yeah
whereabouts are you finding deals mostly
so in terms of sourcing deals my main
two patches are Northeast yeah and
Hartley pool it's kind of weird I'm
based in London London's my other patch
but how I came across that and built a
power team was literally I think I
watched one of your videos again and I
wanted to offer clients the high-end
London properties expensive Northeast
cheaper up there by low rent High yeah
and I just called a few agents and an
agent put me in touch with a builder I
went up there to Hartlepool melt the
Builder we've now got a relationship
where I can trust him to quote work and
carry out the work and even do viewings
for me in fact my first deal I didn't
see the property
he viewed it for me so you're doing
remote deal sourcing partly yeah which I
know we were just chatting with Ross and
Ross was saying to me dude he's saying I
live in the Northeast and I'm deal
sourcing in the Northeast Henry Holmes
is selling more deals than me in my
patch and Henry hands I won't even come
in here they've just got connections
everywhere and they're sending Builders
and using this and this and this so
it's an interesting concept talk to me
about remote deal selling so it takes um
a lot of due diligence
um because you need to to understand
your patch you do need to go there like
I go there at least twice a month okay
it takes also to having someone there
that you can trust to show you the town
to understand what streets work what
streets don't work because when I'm
quoting words for my Builder he's so
knowledgeable about the town he can tell
me that Street's bad and you won't avoid
that because when your packaging and
selling to an investor you don't want at
the end of the day when everything's
done and they have the property they're
struggling to run it out because that's
a bad street or they're going to get a
bad tenant because it's going to affect
your reputation 100 so you're doing
high-end stuff in London you're doing
cheap buy low rent High type stuff in
the north east New Deal selling talk to
me about your rent to rent business so
rent to rent business I've got one
service accommodation I own croodin
that's doing fantastic how much does
that make on average turnover 2.5 profit
about 1.5 about one and a half Grand and
a half Grand yeah and then when you say
so you've got about 1000 pounds mortgage
expenses bills and stuff like that
that's not bad though I also have a JV
Brighton deal and that one is making
between 900 to a thousand pound three
bed property in Brighton is it crazy
that you're just saying all these
figures and whereas you used to work
your ass off for Just Two thousand it's
really crazy Samuel because again it's
like
going back to what you said um when you
see it you can't answer it and also we
normally even talk when it comes to
business or it takes time which you do
have to you know build up the skill the
courage and persistence but to make
money it doesn't have to take long once
you invest in your 100 and you invest in
your skill that skill will then bring
you the income mate I've read so many
business books and they say things like
expect the first two years to make a
loss the third year and fourth year to
break even but five years and I'm like
what kind of business are you running
you know I mean like we've got guys like
you that will come on quit their job
after two weeks then within two three
months making three four five six how
much on average you make in a month with
everything profit with all you different
everything in profit around seven Grand
Seven Grand a month yeah so now we I
just had my first 10 grand profit month
last month so my next goal was to just
make that consistent yeah yeah yeah 10
grand congrats mate why did you want to
come on winners on a Wednesday because I
know you're quite you know your faith is
really important to you you're also big
into inspiring and pulling people up
yeah and encouraging other people what
was it that made you agree to come come
and do this interview because obviously
there's not really much in it for you I
think the main thing like you said is
other people
um it's it's so crazy it's like a full
circle moment where last year
I was watching people on here and I know
you've done a lot of interviews but I
watching people on here saying I'm
making this I'm doing this and just to
be a product again of your amazing
training and your amazing Academy and
even the people who have heard about you
they say oh Ellie are you on Samuels
how's this training you know and I'm
able to say I've done it I've invest in
myself and it's working and it was quite
nerve-wracking even for the first three
months because I didn't want to tell
anyone did to my parents no one else one
of my partner knew no one knew you
didn't tell any friends no you didn't
tell anyone that you'd just taken the
loan out why did you not tell me that
because they wouldn't understand yeah
they wouldn't understand but when I've
heard your story and even other
entrepreneur stories where they bet on
themselves where even to invest in
training they've had to use money they
didn't have I was thinking well surely
I'm no different if I take the same
route and I bet on myself it's going to
work so when I did my tell my parents
after I think about three months that
listen by the way I quit my job I'm
working for myself
they were quite surprised of course
dude you're a dark horse man that's
crazy how's life changed then how's life
now has it affected your relationship
with your wife and stuff I have my own
time another thing that you say is the
most is it the most expensive things in
life are free the best things in life
are free but may as well cost the Earth
if you don't have the time to enjoy them
time time to say I can be at this
appointment in the afternoon yeah I can
make time for family at this time I can
move things around and being able to
give back to people to help other people
get deals understand how deals work it's
just been an amazing amazing experience
honestly what would you say your
strongest reason is for doing this
my strongest reason for doing this
I would say it's just being inspiration
yeah and
I don't want to say that I'm the Savior
or anyone but to go through hard and
tough things so the people around me
don't need to go through them and can
maybe even learn from my mistakes
because even join an academy I don't
believe I just invested in training but
I invested even though some things take
time
the Time of My Success was drastically
reduced because you mentored me because
I had so many peers doing it so I saved
myself time so I want to be that
inspiration and even kind of a Gateway
that's awesome man well dude I'm so
proud of your success happy to see you
growing I know this is just the
beginning for you yeah so I look forward
to seeing where Henry Holmes goes over
the over the next few years and I really
appreciate coming on the uh when it's on
a Wednesday interview thank you Samuel
respect brother
yeah
foreign
[Music]